and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to episode 162 today
we're gonna talk about upgrades
upgrading your phones upgrading your
clothes your technology your housing
your appliances and anything else you
might consider upgrading you're right
it's it's sort of that time of the year
it's a the year is winding down and of
course it's the holiday shopping season
and everyone's out shopping for other
people as well there are a ton of
upgrades available right now right well
and then you you go to the store you're
like I'm gonna buy this gift for someone
and then inevitably like you oh but I'd
really need that computer for me or I
need you know whatever I'd be stupid not
to buy this upgrade that's on sale for
whatever reason right yeah and so
whether you're listening to this is the
holidays or your listen to this months
from now or years from now it's not just
applicable to the holidays we're always
sort of tugged by the the tug of
consumerism can I improve this thing I
think it's part of the human condition
yeah well it's also part of the business
model with companies right like they
totally build in the need to upgrade
it's like I know
Apple and other tech you know gadget
companies they will put out a lesser
version of what they can really do
because they want to they want you to
have that desire for the upgrade so
it'll put it out with you know a phone
that maybe has a few megapixels less
than than the upgrade but but you know
as soon as they put that new up that new
phone out there they're trying to tug it
you trying to get your dollar so you can
you can oh yeah I definitely need those
new megapixels so I'm gonna go and
upgrade my phone yeah we don't even know
what it means half the time what does a
megapixel okay and so you know I I think
you're absolutely right there are these
weird sort of conspiracy theories about
planned obsolescence and and while some
of those things are true there are going
to be some product developers yeah who
deliberately sort of sabotage an item to
work less than it should
right but I think the real planned
obsolescence is in marketing marketing
makes us feel like the thing that we
bought to satisfy our needs is now
obsolete even though it isn't obsolete
and we're gonna talk about that today
we're gonna make some distinctions as
well so Oh before we dive into the
questions today Ryan we're recording
this a little bit earlier recording this
on Cyber Monday mm-hmm
I see podcast Shawn over there right now
taking advantage of all the deals that's
right
he's refreshing his screen but no we we
just went through Black Friday and Small
Business Saturday which Louie then when
did they start Small Business Saturday
it's the day after Black Friday when did
when did they certain mark coining that
term I was a few years ago your thing is
I think it's like big companies like
American Express that coined the small
business I don't know where that
actually comes from so I'm speaking out
of turn here maybe someone in the
YouTube comments can let me know we're
we're small business saturday actually
came from but I think it's I mean we are
small business owners Ryan we own a
couple small businesses and I so I think
it's admirable to want to support local
and small businesses but not if the
price is to still go out and consume
without intention yeah that is still a
problem whether you're supporting your
local business unintentionally or you're
supporting a mega corporation
unintentionally it's still the same
fundamental problem I guess I just don't
understand why I have to wait until the
Saturday after Black Friday to support a
local business well I I think and here's
why because because we all know that
people are good and it's weird to me the
Black Friday is really a thing still and
it's less of a thing now our good friend
Matt Diavel will put up a video about
the the history of Black Friday recently
and it's tapered off significantly in
fact we'll put a link to that video in
the show notes it I know it's been doing
really well a lot of people without
value in it but a tapered off as far as
like what people spend on Black Friday
yeah that you know I mean remember in
our
our documentary as an example where you
have the hordes of people bombarding the
doors of people getting violent over
whatever yeah
whatever they're trying to get on Black
Friday and that's still happening now I
don't want to act like it's not there
are people who are still trying to get
the big screen TV but which is weird I
mean big TVs haven't really changed that
much over the last five six ten years I
mean once they became flat TVs and they
were able to mount them on a wall
everything else is uh it becomes these
the marketing speak though the
megapixels the the 4k the the curves he
the Ray and and sort of some of these
gimmicks but anyway in Matt's video
he showed our friend Dan Harris all it
was on ABC News and they showed that
there were camera crews waiting at one
of the wall I think I was a Walmart
maybe was the best buy one of these the
big chain stores waiting for the the
doorbuster sale at yeah five a.m.
waiting to film all the madness yeah and
one person walked in the front door so
good got this whole like but but the
thing is we're actually spending more
than ever so it's not like well all of a
sudden we've tamp down the consumerism
and the message of minimalism has spread
and now everyone we did our job we're
out yeah we can we can just walk away
now I wish that would happen yeah where
everyone was just more deliberate now so
we're still spending a lot of money
in fact we're spending more and more
each holiday season yes but we're
spending in different ways so Black
Friday isn't as tempting for people it's
I'm guessing that Cyber Monday is taking
on a lot of the the dollars that that
used to be spent on Black Friday yeah I
think so but also it has become Pro to
the the Black Friday has become
protracted so that it starts for some
people on Thanksgiving Day I mean they
have doorbuster sales and I get targeted
like 2 p.m. or something crazy on
Thanksgiving Day but then also I saw a
billboard I was driving to the airport
the other day and I saw this like I
think was Chevy and it was like Black
Friday deals this month that's funny
I said what do you mean this month like
it this month is Black Friday month yeah
it does it doesn't make a whole lot of
sense and so it has
protract which is a good thing if people
aren't trampling each other even if
you're indulging in consumers I gotta
say man I have not like I usually see
these videos floating around on Twitter
or whatever in the news about Black
Friday madness and groups of people you
know just going at each other I haven't
I haven't really seen any you there was
what I think it was I think it was in
Alabama and I'm not sure about this I
don't know if you saw it Sean or Jordan
but where shots were fired I think it
was in a Walmart good yeah yeah I saw
people running from shots being fired
I also saw two guys fighting over a
big-screen television was like yanking
it from each other I'm clearly they're
breaking the TV and the red Xs of
fighting for it and so yeah Black Friday
on Black Friday
I took Ella and woman backs and Ella's
grandparents run down Becca's parents
were in town and we went out to the
Cincinnati Zoo the festival lights they
have the Cincinnati Zoo yeah we did go
to the LA Zoo and then a small business
saturday we support a big business we
went to well actually maybe it's a
medium-sized business or maybe it's a
non-profit the LA Arboretum they have
this I think it's called the moonlight
forest it's all these Chinese lanterns
the team
seemingly goes on endlessly and it is
just it was gorgeous and Ella loved it
it was gifting and experience and she
just really enjoyed well she enjoyed the
the howl she enjoyed Christmas time much
more than she is just they're going to
enjoy that one day of Christmas yeah and
and so sometimes protracting the
holidays could be good when our
intentions are good yeah it doesn't mean
you can't shop on that Friday or or
whatever but when we're compelled
because we're gonna save 30% which by
the way you probably could have saved
that anyway if you just looked somewhere
online but maybe you didn't need to buy
the thing at all yeah I mean it's funny
because like I hear people like I was I
was
than lunch with Travis a guy that Josh
and I used to work with back in the
corporate world and he was like man I've
never done the Black Friday thing he's
like but there's this one particular I
think it was a TV and he's like you know
we do need to replace our TV I was gonna
get one and then I saw what they were
doing on Black Friday and so what we
planned as a family we're gonna go and
get that one thing and then you know
we're going to save you know X amount of
dollars on it and I meant to text them
and see how it went man but I'm assuming
when I write form but I guess that's the
biggest argument I hear for Black Friday
it's a while and I can't afford it
unless you know I went on Black Friday
mm-hmm and I you know there's there's no
judgement towards anyone who has done
that the problem is is that that's
that's more of the exception right
absolutely the rule is usually like we
feel like Oh we'd be stupid not to go
out and buy these things because we're
gonna save all this money buying the
stuff that we probably wouldn't buy
anyway it makes me think of remember the
coupon books you know it's like ten
thousand dollars worth the savings yeah
yeah people will like would go
door-to-door selling them right yeah
there's this cost like 30 40 bucks or
whatever so it's ten thousand dollars
worth of savings but you have to spend
about a hundred grand to get that ten
thousand dollars worth of savings you
don't save money by spending money right
and and I think that's that's the thing
to you we're still in the midst of the
the holiday season right now when you
think about upgrading you think about
buying something you don't need
you're never saving money on it if you
don't actually need that thing man and I
think quite often we we feel like we're
doing this so we can feel more complete
and there's this essay on our website I
will put a link to it in the show notes
as well it's called more complete and I
think this is this is a perfect segue
into the upgrade discussion because
quite often we are upgrading even that
term is it's a marketing term yeah it's
not actually improved purchases I'm not
improving upon what I already have
necessarily and I can be but I've been
told I need to upgrade because the thing
that I have now is obsolete or less
lesson new and of course I need the new
thing my my my five year old car is not
new and shiny enough I have to go get
the brand-new car with the bow on it
with the new car smell and so this is
called more complete a dozen art
galleries adorned the two-mile walk from
my home to our studio
whenever I stroll past the gallery I
often think wouldn't that painting look
great in our living room wouldn't this
picture frame fit perfectly in our
daughter's bedroom wouldn't those photos
complete our dining room but then I
pause to consider my impulses
truth be told our home is already
complete and the perfect bookshelf couch
or chair won't make our home more
complete our things should add value to
our lives they should augment enhance or
amplify our experiences which means fine
get that new coffee table if it makes
sense but it simply doesn't make sense
if the reason is completion things don't
complete us we are already complete amen
and I think that man I get so caught up
in it like if I could just get one more
thing Phil and we justify when you had
that 2,000 square foot condo we feel
empty when our space is empty yeah
but the weird thing is when you look at
the best architects you look at endo or
you look at John Paulson or or these
sort of minimalist architects it's
really about how they use the space how
the space becomes part of the art and I
think our lives are a lot like that how
do we fill our lives with the
appropriate amount of space so it's not
cluttered whether it's mental clutter
physical clutter visual clutter
emotional clutter these are all these
are all areas in which we could afford
more space in our lives and the chaos of
Black Friday to me is what well it's
what illustrates like
it looks like these sort of crazy ant
colonies when they're bombarding the
doors and there's no peace in that
there's no there's no feeling of that's
not complete that that to me is the
definition of incomplete
yeah and so we're chasing complete I
think that's that that is really the the
problem and you know it's funny at Ryan
as I walk through as I walked to the
studio from from my home I see the I see
those those bits of artwork and I do
feel compelled like I think it's part of
the human condition I need that I need
to upgrade my space yeah I need to
improve upon what I already have I mean
we're at that uh was it a farm I don't
if it was a farmers market or uh was
like a little flea market little flea
market thing in LA yeah it's like in
West Hollywood the corner of Melrose and
Fairfax and so there was like the these
prints that we saw in both of us man
there's a really nice prints like those
are really minimal and like it was just
it was very beautiful prints and like my
first inclination was man like I could
totally get one of these prints and
frame it and it would look really nice
and then I'm like where would that look
nice in my home and then justifying like
well eventually I'll find a place for
that right yeah well I'll find somewhere
to cram it and then that's not and
that's not intentional it's like well
that's the just in case thing I'm gonna
do this just in case I'm going to
upgrade my space just in case yeah our
first question today is from Becca in
Indiana is there a certain point at
which you can justify getting rid of
something and replacing it with
something different even if the initial
item works perfectly well for example I
have baby clothes I have saved that I
have used for my three children and you
are planning on having more children
eventually however the clothes I have
aren't necessarily what I would choose
now if I were to go start over so seeing
was like something like dishes like if I
have cups that work perfectly well but I
would really prefer to have a different
sort of cup can it really be justified
replacing it you know I dig this
question Ryan because well it's it's a
nuanced question
because it seems to me that Becca isn't
just trying to she's being intentional
about yeah there are some things in my
life my preference has changed or I've
become more refined over time there are
some things in my life that I would I
would prefer to have something different
and she's saying when can I justify it
and I actually think that word is is is
the problem because quite often we can
justify it anything man
absolutely I bet you if you give me 48
hours and and a piece of paper I will
write you a really good justification
one that's fairly sound at least in my
mind because that's the only person I
needed really justify it yeah I could
justify buying a Lamborghini Ryan yeah
dude we could justify buying a
helicopter I mean if we really sat there
and looked for reasons I you know I
think when it comes to that word justify
the question that I ask myself is why am
I trying to justify this I
- whom am I trying to just yeah man yeah
because if it's like if I'm justifying
something just to give myself permission
to do something that I typically
wouldn't do like for me that's the wrong
reason for me to justify something yeah
and yeah if it's if it's just if it's to
justify it to myself I've got to examine
that and really ask like what is it that
I'm after here with me with cell phones
for example like I still got the iPhone
5 it's slow as heck because Apple does
not update they don't fix the software
they intentionally let the phone slow
down that came out in the news let
earlier this year so like they
intentionally let the phone get slower
so you can justify getting another phone
and so I could justify that I could look
at that and say oh my phone's really
slow and I need to get that iPhone 10 or
maybe I don't go all out and I get the
iPhone eight I don't know what happened
to the iPhone 9 but uh yeah I could go
anyone I have I could go get the iPhone
eight and I get totally justify that
it's got a better camera and it's gonna
be faster I mean those are - those are
two pretty valid reasons to justify but
when I really examine it I wish I didn't
phone at all first off so I don't really
want my phone to be me faster I don't
want to be able to pacify myself easier
yeah III in fact um I have you know I've
talked about this I haven't really
pulled the trigger on it yet but like
I've talked to you about you've talked
to me about getting it like a flip phone
and I mean I think that's what Liam
about - still does he stills got like a
dumb phone I guess is what you would
call it yeah but but yes
Becca you can absolutely justify
anything but I think with her question
man it goes back to what you're talking
about doing her preferences when she
talked about with her preferences like
the baby clothes right or the dishes
right and so the question that I wrote
down for Becca and this is a question
that anyone needs to ask themselves is
can you afford your new preferences
yeah because yes I mean maybe I would
prefer to own a Range Rover I think
they're beautiful cars but they're also
like a hundred thousand dollar car and I
can't afford that preference is the
Range Rover is that the one where they
say by two of them's because one's
always in the shop so so really you have
to buy two of them if you're gonna buy
one well I could just keep my Toyota for
when the but then I'm gonna be
discontented because I'm not driving the
Range Rover yeah and so I think a Range
Rover is a just a gorgeous car I really
do think it's a piece of art so it's a
moving piece of art and unfortunately it
I don't have unlimited money and so I
can't I can't truly afford it I also
can't afford all the times I would be
taking it to the shop and in all these
additional costs that are embedded in
that I think the other thing too for me
is like when I think about the Tesla and
I talked about this a few episodes ago
where you know Mariah and I we had a
savings account set aside for a Tesla
and those cost 60,000 like the one I was
looking at all wheel drive it's the
model three it was like 60 grand and I
was you know saving up I did we had ten
fifteen thousand dollars saved up and I
was thinking about dropping that money
on the Tesla just the $15,000 and that
was something I couldn't do because when
I asked myself you know not not only
like can I afford to buy this Tesla
but the the question I asked myself was
as can I afford to buy this Tesla and
also not afford to build schools in in
Thailand what's the other use of this
money what's your sort of opportunity
cost there is this the best use of this
money for me and it's not a judgment by
the way if you were to say yes this
Range Rover or this Tesla or these new
baby clothes or these new dishes are the
best use of this money for me that's up
to you to determine now I like the way
she looked at if she said you know what
if I had to do this again would I buy
these items again it sounds to me like
the answer is no now if you're thinking
about getting rid of something that is
the perfect question for you to ask
yourself I love that if you're gonna get
rid of something then ask yourself would
I buy this again if the answer's no then
yeah you probably want to get rid of it
now if you're talking about upgrading
the thing or the word she used which I
like a lot better replacing the thing
because to me replacing is far more
important than upgrading because we get
to a point where okay let's say your
phone just smashes into a thousand
pieces right Ryan are you going to
upgrade it well maybe maybe you need a
different version or just the newer
version that's out yeah or maybe that
version that I broke isn't available
anymore right or maybe you can just
replace it with something else maybe
it's the dumb phone maybe it's another
iPhone 5 that's used if you're replacing
it that is often intentional and then so
the question is what am I going to
replace this with is that's a much
better question man I think cuz it's
like you instead of asking yourself am i
doing this to upgrade like you know
Becca needs to ask herself am i doing
this to replace the items it's a like
you said it's much more intentional yes
indeed so Becca I would love to send you
a copy of our book essential it is an
essay collection with 150 different
essays here Jordan which cameras is this
one alright beautiful it's an essay
collection with 150 different essays
about simple living about intentional
living there are two chapters in here in
particular that I think
find a lot of value and there's a
chapter about minimalism it's the first
chapter and there's another chapter in
there about stuff and so when you're
talking about replacing your stuff
getting rid of your stuff some rules
around the stuff in your life we have
those rules in essential so Sean if you
could reach out to Becca and send her a
copy of essential either the book
version or if you liked our podcast
you'll love the audiobook version of
essential or if you just want the e-book
we'll be happy to send that to you as
well you know I just want to go back to
that question you asked about can I
afford it and you know what when I think
about when I used to upgrade and you
know the in the days of yesteryear right
I didn't ask myself if I could really
afford it I guess maybe I asked myself
if I could afford the debt payment or if
I could have if I could afford maybe
that in you know in that instant if I
had the cash on me but it's funny man
like when I look at my past decisions
being in debt with a mortgage being in
debt with a car being in debt with
credit cards being in debt with student
loans I couldn't afford anything no but
somehow you were broke even though
ostensibly you weren't yeah and and you
know I could find ways to justify buying
different things but ultimately I mean
now I look at my life if I am in debt
and I want to buy something that I'd
necessarily don't need if I'm in debt I
can't I'm broke I can't afford it
so Becca you know just just don't think
of the monetary costs either to think
about the space they have to take up
think about the the care that you have
to have for those clothes but
psychological weight of holding on to
them even though you don't like them
yeah and so there there are all kinds of
additional costs that are embedded in
holding on to items also bringing new
items in and we have to we have to keep
in mind all of those costs yeah all
right Joe we'd love to hear what you
have to say so if you have a comment or
a tip about upgrading including advice
for any of our callers or question
askers today this is my favorite part of
the show we're at the very end of the
show we we share your comments and your
tips with our listeners so quick pro tip
if you're gonna call in which by the way
the number is 406 to one nine seven
eight three nine or you can send a voice
memo to podcast at the minimalists com
but if you're going to call in
please write your question or your
comment out first and that way you have
a much better chance of being on air but
also you'll sound far more articulate
but we definitely need more comments
from our listeners we're looking for
your comments about upgrading or any of
the other topics that we're talking
about and because here's the thing Ryan
and I aren't experts we just talk about
all these things we're experts in our
own lives sometimes we just like to talk
about ourselves and it helps a lot of
people yes and just take it for what it
is you know and we want you to talk
about yourself what's working for you
absolutely so share your comments with
us because you're gonna be sharing them
with hundreds of thousands if not
millions of other people when you call
us up 406 to 1 9 7 8 3 9 or voice memo
to podcast at the minimalists comm where
our favorite comments and tips on a
future episode and stay tuned to the end
of this week's episode for this week's
listener comments and tips Ryan what
time is it you know what time it is it's
time for our lightning round where we
answer questions from social media
indeed we do we're on Twitter Facebook
and Instagram
we're at the mentalists on all of those
social media platforms during the
lightning round this is where Ryan and I
each do our best to answer every
question with just a short shareable
less than 140 character response we also
put the text to these minimal Maxim's in
the show notes so you can copy and share
our pit the answers on social media if
you'd like and now you can find all of
our pithy quotes in one place thanks to
our good friend Jessica Lynn Williams
you can just go over to minimal Maxim's
dot-com
alrighty our first letting run question
is from Austin from Nashville this is
the Austin who was at our Nashville
event who got up on stage and played his
song when you invited him on that's like
one of my favorite events ma'am
that was that was so cool that was
during the the PostScript portion of of
the national event so if you haven't
checked that out if your patreon
subscriber you you can find that over
there but Austin he was like terrified
he he got up and he asked about this
question and he was like look I I I just
want to play music in front of people
but I'm I'm scared to do it and what
should I do
and Ryan was like well you're in a
sold-out venue right now why don't you
come up here and there's a guitar right
here on stage because we had Canyon City
who opened up for us
why don't you play us
in front of all these hundreds of people
and he got up there and he rocked it and
it was it was really great so all of
them has a question for us
I just I love how like Rachel looked
over and she's like did you guys plan
this look is Rachel cruises our guests
like no we did not it was it was a truly
special night all right that could have
gone really bad too yeah it could have
just been some guy who had never picked
up a guitar saying before we booed him
off the stage no Austin if you're
listening man we love you dude and we're
so proud of you and he came out with an
album recently too which is pretty cool
Austin's question is how do you combat
the want to upgrade even though what you
currently have is enough what practices
do you use to deter the I need to
upgrade mindset when it was never a need
to begin with well my short answer for
you Austin is every upgrade is also a
downgrade hmm and here's what I mean by
that like let's say Ryan does need to
upgrade his phone he's gonna downgrade
his bank account in doing so right but
also it's a downgrade and what else you
could have used that money for the
alternatives for that money for
something else maybe you were going to
donate some of the money to charity
maybe you're going to use that money to
buy some really high quality food so you
can make a dinner for you and Mariah
these are all down grades in other areas
of your life and you have to you have to
recognize that they're all these
additional costs now also you talked
about this at the top of the show Ryan
but I here are some stats that will help
put this into even more perspective here
so according to CNBC 28% of shoppers are
still in debt from last year's Christmas
shopping so so you're out Christmas
shopping right now and you're in it your
if your one in for one of those one in
four people you're still in debt from
last year and then so what do you have
to do you're piling on more debt in
order unbelievable man
and and and and so if you're what if you
if you are one of those one in four
people who still end up from last year
why don't you ask your family for a
debt-free Christmas and so you don't
have to go into any more debt yes to buy
more gifts and doesn't mean you have to
like be mr. Grinch about Christmas you
can still have experiences you can enjoy
each other and in fact well later in
this episode we'll talk about some of
those experiences but to continue on
with that stat the average shopper even
though twenty-eight percent of folks are
in debt from last Christmas the average
shopper still plans on spending seven
hundred and seventy six dollars on gifts
this holiday season it's a new record by
the way and it's also a fifty percent
increase from just four years ago and so
we're spending more more money than ever
we're in more debt than ever and we're
buying things obligatory for people who
don't necessarily even want them with
money we don't even have by the way and
I think I think we can change this so
Austin from Nashville the thing that I
will tell you is if you feel like I need
to upgrade but you what you have is
already enough then you can't make
something more enough right we were
talking about the more complete essay
earlier yeah
it's grammatically incorrect to say more
complete that's why that's why I wrote
it that way because you can't make
something more complete if you have a if
we put a giant puzzle on this table Ryan
and there were a thousand pieces in the
puzzle and you and I got down to the
last two or three pieces it's an
incomplete puzzle until we do complete
it right but now if all 1,000 pieces are
here on the table and you all sent out
of your pocket you pull out 17 new
puzzle pieces and throw them on top it's
not a more complete puzzle in fact it's
less complete now because it's
obstructed yeah and so Austin you may be
obstructing your your life by trying to
have more than enough yeah man I would I
would say this man if an upgrade plate
is you in debt or worse if it places you
deeper in debt
then you've downgraded the quality of
your life and like that's when I think
about upgrading I mean that is what I
think about it the costs that it's going
to take is it not just the monetary cost
but again the stuff that we talked about
with Becca's question can I take care of
it can I afford the upkeep can I afford
the space can I afford the mental
capacity to worry about that thing and
the honest answer is is probably what
you have now is enough now I've been
trying to think of something where it
makes sense to upgrade and I'm thinking
about Jordans computer and how when he
first started working for us he didn't
have his computer wasn't able to you
know do the video that that we asked him
to do so we indeed had to buy him an
upgraded computer so he could so he
could do the job that we were asking
because there was something in the way
currently and the only way for us to
overcome that hurdle was to replace it
with some with a better version that
could do what he needed it to do that's
another great question to ask - is is is
having this current version whatever it
is is it in the way of me living a more
meaningful life I mean you think about
before the printing press was invented
and people had to literally write books
out by hand books were especially rare
and you couldn't disseminate information
and when the printing press came along
if you were a person who was like well I
I can still I still only going to write
this out by hand you are going to be
held back because of this technological
advance is there and so it's it's less
about justifying it for the sake of
justifying it and actually being more
productive being more efficient but also
creating a better version of what you
are without whatever you are trying to
create PS Ryan we have a couple more
really great questions here Tina from
Toronto says Casey nice that has a
saying mending is better than ending he
mostly uses it for ripped jeans but with
today's planned obsolescence what are
some considerations you make between
getting costly repairs done versus
getting upgrades and then Arlen also
asks last year I finally upgraded my
iPad Mini to an iPad pro and this one
this one's a long question someone's
gonna get to the to the end of it here
but basically what she is asking here
she said what do people do with their
old technology when they're done with it
if it's beat even if it isn't beyond
repair so you have this old phone that
it's it's obsolete now alright
theoretically obsolete what what the
heck do I do with but it still works but
it still works in some capacities right
question maybe it no longer works for
you but it still might work for someone
what do you do with it specifically well
what are some tips and some tricks that
you can you will help our audience out
here and so if you like to hear our
answers to those questions you can
listen to this week's PostScript episode
over at the minimalists private podcast
that's right every week we record an
additional podcast episode and it's
available exclusively to our patreon
subscribers so if you want to support
our show and keep this podcast 100%
advertisement free then head on over to
the minimalists comm slash support in
addition to our weekly PostScript
episodes the minimalist private podcast
feed includes our ask the minimalist
anything episodes unreleased recordings
of our live events and the entire back
catalogue of past private episodes once
you've become a subscriber you will also
receive a personal link to our private
podcast feed so that it plays in your
normal podcast player you can find all
the details and all the good stuff
including an additional podcast episode
every week over at the minimalists comm
slash support and here is a snippet from
this week's PostScript episode
[Music]
if something is ending yeah or coming up
so it in yeah
then we have some questions to face
first question is do I in this do I
pitch it recycle it do I donate it we'll
talk about that in a moment like how do
you make that distinction there but then
also do I mend it do I repair the thing
or I like the third option I like the
least throw it in there it's not always
the right path but notice there aren't
just to pass this isn't binary right the
third path is can I live without it yeah
didn't really need it in fact well maybe
my life just maybe my life will be
better without it okay now it's time for
our added value portion of the show this
is where we talk about something that
has added value to our lives recently I
got two things Ryan well I was I just
finished reading Jonathan Franzen's new
book it's called the end of the end of
the earth hmm it's an essay collection
and it really made me appreciate how
good his writing is but that's not my
added value today because it's the book
I'd be least likely to recommend of his
it's a good book and and his writing is
phenomenal but if you're looking for an
introduction into Jonathan Franzen's
work and who I think is the great
American novelist I mean I think his
writing is he's the top five living
writers for sure but one of my favorite
books of all time is freedom so reading
this new book reminded you how good
freedom was exactly that's great but
also I think freedom is the Great
American Novel of our generation it's
like the Great Gatsby of our generation
and it will be the book a hundred years
from now I think people be pointing back
on and it is I mean it's a great story
the writing is beautiful the characters
are so memorable and you lie it's told
from four different points of view but
not in a confusing way at all oh it's
good and yeah so that could get really
convoluted real quick but there are
these large swaths these large sections
where patty is the main character
and she's the wife of Walter of Walt who
is another character and there's Richard
Katz who's like this musician and then
their son Patti and and Walt's son and
and each perspective you start to
identify with that character and then by
the end of the book you're like I really
identify with this person and then you
look at other people in your life and
you're like yeah like Ryan is the
Richard Katz to my Walter or whatever
like but you you start to you pick up
these dynamics but then you just he he
captures the internal life the interior
life like what's going on inside my head
and my heart so well like the
frustration we feel with other people
the agony we feel with our relationships
the discontent we feel with our creative
endeavors and it's such but it's such a
digestible book - it's not like some you
know crazy avant-garde postmodern screed
from metafiction from the 60s or
something it's it's a phenomenal but I
think came out in oh nine and it's one
of my favorite books that I've ever read
and speaking of things that came out
around that time Beck's and I were
driving around with all of this weekend
we look for some calming soothing music
because it's nighttime and we just
finished going to the LA Arboretum or
maybe it was the Cincinnati Zoo I don't
remember which no we were coming back
from the Arboretum and so it was a long
drive back we're looking for something
soothing and there is a
singer-songwriter named Peter Bradley
Adams and his first album is called
leave-taking and it is it was a perfect
album I mean I don't really know how
else to describe it so he now he's
continued to make albums he's one of
those artists who's able to continue
with the same sound over and over and
over and still somehow make new albums
but this first album of his is like a
culmination of life's work it felt like
and it's so good but it's also like so
soothing every time I turn it on like
I'm transported back to 2008-2009 when I
was first less into this out it's like
an anchor
for that period of my life and it was
can't promise I'll do the same thing for
you that it's done for me but it is such
a gorgeous album the the pianos on the
instrumentation the his vocals the
writing he does he has some of these
lines that just stay with you so yeah
you can check both those out freedom by
Jonathan Franzen that's a book I
recommend and leave-taking by Peter
Bradley Adams
so those are two recommendations for you
today if you move on the right here
right now let's do it all right let's
talk about what's going on in the lives
of the minimalist well we have a new
essay over at the minimalists calm
it's called ideas for a debt-free
holiday so Ryan and I we went out to
some of our friends we talked to them
about their what experiences have you
enjoyed getting or giving recently and
then if you do have to get physical
items what are some of the physical
gifts that you enjoy getting or giving
and then also what about charitable
giving and so having a more meaningful
holiday but also having a less expensive
a debt-free holiday you don't have to be
one of those people who's who's
careening towards spending a thousand
dollars on gifts for people that they
don't want and so we have some more
meaningful experiences over there I'll
put a link to that in the show notes as
well speaking of Christmas now is the
perfect time to buy a brick for
Christmas like an actual brick yeah well
you know it's funny so so many funny
when I tweeted out that essay of ours
oh yeah the buying of a brick yeah yeah
and so buy a brick for Christmas Ryan
and I are trying to build this this
co-op in Dayton Ohio it's a
not-for-profit grocery store on the west
side of Dayton because well it's a
relatively poor neighborhood but it's
also Washington say relatively I guess
relative to all of the United States
it's a poor neighborhood there isn't a
single grocery store on the west side of
date and 40% of the Dayton's population
lives on the west side they don't have
access to carrots and cabbage and and
just good grocery store food unless they
get on several buses and spend half a
day grocery shopping yeah which people
you know it's obviously hard to do and
we're trying to change that in West
Dayton we've partnered up with Jim City
Market we're trying to raise the final
100 thousand dollars to get this grocery
co-op built
and you can help us out you just go to
the minimalists comm slash or brick and
we did a really good video with with
Jordan and and Sean we but you and I
like I by the way you're such a better
actor than I am it was so good it was
like all subtle oh oh keep going well in
the video like Ryan's trying to pull lay
a brick out of a wall because he is
trying to get bricks to build this co-op
we've learned that you know the average
brick with labor costs about a dollar
for this co-op and so we're trying to
buy in quotes by a hundred thousand
bricks and Ryan and I are donating
$25,000 of our own money to buy twenty
five thousand bricks effectively but we
need your help raising the rest of the
money and we are over sixty percent of
the way there outstanding and we need to
get there by the end of the year so if
you can help us get there it's it's it's
going to take a lot still so buy more
than one brick your family you can buy a
brick for your entire family or a person
for each each person in your family and
you can do it in behalf on behalf of so
you just print this receipt out and you
can hand it to them you could even put a
nice themed gift wrapping or a beautiful
envelope and say hey I bought you a
brick for for Christmas and you know
what's funny about this LS all the video
and so we were out walking yesterday her
and I were walking to the bookstore and
along the way she like picked up a brick
and she was trying to it was like a
broken one cuz she couldn't she goes
here well this helped you build the
store adorable yeah and so you can
definitely help out you can help us do
something meaningful this holiday season
just go to the minimalists comm slash
brick if you want to comment on this
episode you can do so over at
youtube.com slash the minimalist also on
youtube right now we're doing one
quickie episode a week so quickie
podcast for our YouTube audience so
those are usually about four to twenty
minutes long also living room
conversations where we go to our living
rooms we answer your questions some
simple advice about simple living one of
those every Wednesday and pretty soon
we're going to do a house tour of Ryan's
house my house and you can see that all
over at youtube.com
the minimalists and we're also doing
something called simple sundaes right
now every Sunday we send out some sort
of simple living essay or writing about
about living more intentionally so if
you want those in your inbox you can
just head on over to the minimalists com
sign up for email list over there every
Sunday we'll send you some sort of
simple living tips tricks essays
writings ponderings musings so on and oh
end by the way if you do sign up for our
email list we'll never send you any spam
but we will send you some show notes
anytime you hear us talk about the show
notes for our podcast podcast Shawn
write something down and that will show
up in your inbox anytime we put out a
new podcast episode and the next week we
got Jordan Harbinger is gonna be on the
podcast we're gonna talk to him about
starting a business restarting a
business he he had to go through a whole
bunch of stuff recently I'm looking
forward to talking to him he had to walk
away from a previous business and start
you know a phoenix rising from the ashes
of a previous business because he had a
disagreement with some business partners
and he had to start he had to start from
scratch and so a lot of lessons he's
learned Ryan you and I have learned a
lot about business over the last 20 plus
years yeah definitely well share some of
those lessons with you next week Ryan
what else you got for us you know I just
wanted to encourage people to read more
and get informed it's just important man
to like stay abreast of everything
that's going on with our world it's it
is a meme corked culture that we live in
and if we are just reading headlines and
if we're just reading memes well we're
actually not that informed so get out
there and and you know like like I
always say it's great that you guys
listen to Josh and I we think we're
awesome but definitely get out there and
get some different opinions and some
different perspectives
yeah address the actual text of things
you know I was having this conversation
with our good friend Sean mihalick
recently he works with me on how to
write better the the writing class that
I teach and he was talking about you
know we often talk about you know Henry
David Thoreau or someone like someone
like that or Emerson and but rarely do
we actually go back and and and and dive
deep into the text of something
and really understanding instead we go
and read the listicle write the top 10
things the Henry David Thoreau said
about simple living and that can be
helpful the surface surface level level
stuff can be a nice entrance and into it
but then how do we go beyond the surface
level so yeah we can do that by by
getting informed and and reading more
reading different perspectives yeah
ma'am hey I also got some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners
check them out
hi guys I'm a loose I'm from the
Netherlands and I live in Belgium I have
a little tip for holiday planning and
gift-giving recently I was listening to
your podcast about Black Friday and I
think you mentioned in your podcast as
well that although Black Friday is a
very American phenomenon it has spread
to other countries and yes it has spread
to the Netherlands and Belgium as well
and the timing cannot be more perfect
for businesses in December the Dutch and
Belgians celebrate Christmas as well as
sinter Klass which is on the 5th of
December Sinterklaas is roughly the same
concept as Santa Claus namely
gift-giving which actually creates a
good opportunity many Dutch families
deliberately choose whether or not they
give gifts on each holiday for example
some families celebrate sinter Klass
with gifts and celebrate Christmas with
a nice meal with the family and other
families do the exact opposite it's
actually a clever strategy that you can
apply to many occasions there are so
many celebrations throughout the year
Valentine's Day Easter Thanksgiving
Christmas save the class if you want to
be deliberate you can choose which one
she celebrates small and for which you
really go all out if you want for which
ones you want to buy gifts and which
ones you want to celebrate without gifts
you can choose how you want to reshape
your holidays high minimalist this is
Stephanie Reynolds from San Antonio
Texas and I wanted to offer a new
resource for those women out there who
really love their clothes or accessories
but they want to minimize their closet
and it's a service called litotes
le t OTE and it's basically a clothes
rental company so every month you get of
of a certain number of items that you
get you wear them as much as you want
for the month you don't have to wash
them and then you send them back so you
can keep your minimalist closet but also
stay on trying to enjoy some latest
fashions every month without clogging
your closet this is on your episode
regarding addiction I was listening to
you guys talk about the how it can be
healthy to remove yourself from an
individual but that removal of the
situation doesn't necessarily need to be
permanent and I really think that that's
true because I dealt with parents and
siblings with addiction problems and
making bad decision because of those
addictions and I found that when you set
such limiting terms on a relationship
like that's it we're done
divorce or I've never you're not my
sibling anymore or you know when it
comes to such permanence it's really not
motivating anymore well you've already
written me off or you've already decided
that I am not worth your time so why am
i motivated to maintain a relationship
with you or value what you have to say I
feel like you really have to speak in
the terms of well right now I'm
struggling with the way that you're
behaving or the the choices you're
making or you know the effect that
you're having on this family and you can
say well right now I need you to not
live here or I can't financially support
you or whatever however it is that you
feel your quote unquote either enabling
or supporting whatever it is make it as
a motivating factor for them like the
way things are going right now I can't
be this close family member or your wife
or your daughter or whatever it is like
but I would like to in the future and
when you do decide to make different
choices or however you want to phrase it
then I would like to continue to do that
and I'm really excited for that to
happen in the future so feel like that
would be like a very non-confrontational
not a end-all be-all way to really make
someone know that you're not happy with
the way things
are going it's affecting you and again
like you said before responsibility it's
not my responsibility to change your
behavior but it is my responsibility to
control what comes in and out of my life
and how it makes me feel and and when
you are ready I would like to revisit
the situation of us being in a close
relationship and I think that's kind of
helped me have a better attitude on it
and it really I feel like motivates that
person like if you want a relationship
then we can revisit we can always
revisit I obviously still care about you
but just I can't right now with the way
things are going all right Joe that's it
for this episode if you have a question
for the minimalists give us a call also
if you have a comment I'd love to hear
your comments the end of these episodes
give us a call for 0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 you
can also email a voice memo to podcast
at the minimalists comm and if you leave
here with just one message we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
and minimus